our alcohols actually making you fat so
recently on my show I had a lady call in
and she wanted to know why she gained
four pounds of weight after she did a
keto meal she cooked for her family I
think it might have been Thanksgiving
she had the meal and then she had the
chocolate chip cookies and she was using
alternative sweeteners sugar alcohols
but she still gained four pounds so
let's talk about that for those of you
that are new to sugar alcohols well this
would be an example of we throw tall
Zala tall there's a whole bunch of them
I'll put a link down below for more
information but these are compounds that
are sweet and they're derived from sugar
but they don't have the same response as
sugar they don't spike insulin and they
also have less calories for example
sugar calories has four calories per
gram these have one point three to two
possibly three calories per gram so the
three big side effects from sugar
alcohols are bloating gas in diarrhea
these usually happen when you consume
excessive amounts anything over like 25
grams but some people are very sensitive
to them and if they just consume like 10
grams they can get diarrhea so there's
another difference between sugar and
sugar alcohol sugar gets absorbed in the
small intestines a hundred percent sugar
alcohols do not get absorbed in the
small intestine now think about you have
23 feet of tubing or piping or plumbing
before it hits the large intestine so
sugar alcohols are dealt with by
microbes in the large intestines then
that's where you may have a reaction if
you consume too much so you have this
compound this sugar alcohol that is
absorbed slowly through the system but
the microbes can ferment it and that's
where you get the gas okay so there's
the microbes are trying to eat it and
they can start producing some of the gas
and create a lot of water attention this
is before the diarrhea okay so when you
gain weight when you consume foods with
sugar alcohols
its water weight it's not actual fat
other people can consume them in smaller
amounts but if you're finding that you
continue to gain weight every time you
do this you're gonna have to avoid them
so it's really a situation you're gonna
have to test the waters some people can
consume these without any water
attention they can still lose weight
other people cannot but the big point I
want to bring up about sugar alcohols is
that you're not gaining fat you are
retaining fluid completely different
situation so all of these desserts made
with sugar alcohols are really meant to
help you in the transition coming off
sugar there's gonna be a point when you
don't need them anymore because you have
no more cravings so from my reality
using sugar alcohols is really a
temporary thing it's not a long-term
solution alright thanks for watching hey
guys I'm not sure if you have my app yet
dr. Berg app it's totally free you
should download it ok this is what it
looks like you click it it gives you all
sorts of great resources I have all my
youtube videos on this out ok and it's
regularly uploading the most recent ones
all the YouTube videos are also
converted to audio versions ok so you
can use it when you're walking
exercising driving your car I have a
mini chorus on there I'll be putting
additional courses I have a lot of
recipes on there and this is new and
also PDF resources so there's various
downloads PDFs that you can get as well
and if you wouldn't mind after you
download it check it out give me your
unbiased review and tell me how you like
it I want to know